that is what all all of them did that's
what Napoleon did that's what Hitler did
uh that's what Caesar did is this like
taking tons of resources and focusing
them on a very small Point taking lots
of gravity and to kind of narrowing the
focus
[Music]
hey my first million fans this is
producer Ben I'm subbing in this week
because Sean is out with some family
stuff but for one question Friday today
Sam and I sat down to discuss how to
take over the world some things that I
have learned from studying lives of
great Achievers and conquers throughout
history and Sam and I just got to
talking about history and great people
in our own lives and what we've learned
from them so
um it's a little bit of a more random
and less focused one question Friday but
I think there's some really good stuff
in it
um that I think you'll really enjoy
so I asked you
traits of conquerors and the reason I'm
thinking about that is I just finished
this like Epic book it's like 1400 pages
long it's called
the uh what is it called the I think
it's the rise and fall of the Third
Reich have you heard of that yeah so
it's kind of one of the seminal texts on
Hitler and Nazism yes and it's crazy and
I was reading it and I was like
this is nuts that the reason I read it
was I wanted to figure out why would why
would like a country com you know be so
complicit with such bad things and I was
like what on Earth was about this Hitler
dude that like convinced all these
people to do all these these bad things
and so I learned and it was wild and I
started and basically it all kind of
came down to like he was in prison one
time because he like tried to like
basically was a glorified protester like
I do he kind of like stormed the it was
like storming the capital kind of like
type of thing and he was arrested for it
and uh in prison he wrote his book
called Mein Kampf and in the book he
wrote like I've I've recently discovered
that it is my obligation to lead the
German people to Greatness and he like
dedicated his life to that and it was
wild that there was like a decision to
be made and like it was almost perfect
execution I mean you know it wasn't in
the end because he uh didn't achieve his
whatever he was trying to achieve but
like he got so freaking far so past what
like
what I ever would have thought and at
the time when when Nazis came to or
right before they came to power they
were the the freaks of Germany like at
the time they were like they had a lot
of homosexuals in their in in the crew
which was like not looked on nicely you
know at that time they had like a bunch
of artists a bunch of like oddballs
people who were like had a lot of
anti-social Behavior like they dressed
funny like people were like who these
guys are a joke No One's Gonna Take
these idiots seriously and it you know
it changed quickly and so anyway I
thought that was fascinating about
conquerors and like these types of
people and like how on Earth they they
came to be and so I wanted to ask you
like what are some common traits amongst
those do you feel weird learning lessons
from the life of Hitler
no because I I well I'm not necessarily
learning a lesson that I want to emulate
like but that said I do think you can
learn good lessons from bad people like
that's you definitely can learn a good
lesson from a bad person
um that there's no doubt about that like
you can look and and like I mean
everyone's bad in someone's eyes but
like I can read about Napoleon and learn
about like war and strategy and apply
that to like business so I can I can
always learn good lessons from bad
people but uh I do I just wanted to
learn like
why did we do this why did so many
people go along with this crap so here's
the thing
here's a lesson I learned from Sean Mr
Beast and Hitler okay there's your head
oh my God but so here's the this is this
was so fascinating to me
so uh we're do this Camp MFM thing and
we're at Cameron Indoor Stadium and
they decide to do a half court shoot off
between Sean and Mr Beast for ten
thousand dollars right and it's
basically Mr Beast goes Sean if you make
a shot at half court I'll give you ten
thousand dollars and Sean goes will you
give me 10 grand in Bitcoin he goes sure
let's do it
so yeah I think in the end told him that
he'd give him 10 grand actually in
pennies uh I don't know if he ended up
doing that or not but so
um they're going to go start shooting at
half court and Sean turns to the camera
and does
his cheesiest like he's joking around Mr
Beast impression and he goes
I'm about to shoot from half court with
Mr Beast in whichever one of us makes it
first is gonna make ten thousand dollars
right totally Hamming it up uh kind of
poking fun at himself right the funny
thing is when we post a video it
actually popped off it went viral on
Tick Tock his little really yeah yeah
that was one of our videos that is uh I
think in the millions of years if not
it's in the hundreds of thousands of
views on uh on reels and on Tick Tock
and what it realized in my mind what
clicked in my mind when I saw that is oh
like it's actually
not that hard to figure out what you're
supposed to do to be successful in this
kind of stuff just very few people are
willing to commit to the bit fully right
like Mr Beast fully commits it a bit
like he actually does that every time he
looks at the camera I'm about to give a
hundred thousand dollars away to these
people if they eat a cockroach or
whatever he says right and he fully
commits to it and Hitler is the same
thing like you go and you watch those
speeches and he's ridiculous right he's
gesticulating he's yelling he's
screaming
um but he like fully committed to
being Hitler to like representing you
know German greatness and and the Aryan
race or whatever but like he didn't care
he everyone thought he looked ridiculous
outside of Germany right like tons of
people mocked and made fun of Hitler he
was very mockable very easy to make fun
of and you can easily make fun of Mr
Beast and think he does sorry Mr Beast
for comparing you to Hitler but like
that idea of just like
throw away your shame and embarrassment
whatever you're trying to do just fully
commit to the bit and you're going to be
really successful I think that's very
true
dude I uh and I want to talk about like
other people and what they had in common
but like the like I was like
emotional reading this thing so
basically Joseph Goebbels is is it
globals gerbils he was like head of
propaganda and this guy like if you
Google him he looks like the most evil
person on Earth and uh he he's he was a
horrible guy and he wrote in a journal
throughout this whole process like he
was journaling like crazy so this book
cited his journal and they tell the
story of basically Hitler has just
killed himself and Joseph Goebel
Goebbels and his wife have I think five
or six kids and they write in their
diary and tell people they're like well
we're gonna go and kill our kids right
now then we're gonna kill ourselves
because
us and our children belong to the fuhrer
to the Third Reich and if the Third
Reich won't exist we do not deserve to
exist either
and I like I was like that's just like
the worst crime I mean I don't know
about the worst because they did so many
horrible things but I mean they just
went and killed their their children six
of them all below 12 years old and I was
like this is the power of that Charisma
or whatever it was had over people that
like
they they went committed I mean all they
obviously we killed or not we but they
killed five or six million people there
was it was horrible but like that act is
even more intimate in some regards and I
remember reading that I'm like holy crap
I could not believe that this person
this evil guy got all these people to do
this crazy it was that was one of
the more emotional periods uh of that
book yeah that's tough that's tough okay
let's talk a little bit like kind of
military strategy and good strategy like
let's let's pivot from the darkness a
little bit
um
so uh common attributes of great
conquerors so one of the things that I
think is interesting have you heard of
blitzkrieg
uh it basically is a it's a German thing
where it says like when they attacked
they they kind of go all out for short
periods right like uh the opposite of
what world war one was wasn't it yes so
it means lightning attacks or lightning
strikes and uh the idea is it's these
short quick
like uh attacks uh before you know you
shock the enemy and and uh go go faster
than they expect what's interesting to
me is that Blitzkrieg is was sort of a
marketing stunt it wasn't anything that
the Nazis talked about internally
um
it's really something of like an
American invention uh to explain German
success
um what the Germans actually talked
about uh was this word
um
oh I can't remember the word in German
um but um it essentially means gravity
uh looking it up swear punked uh it and
it means gravity and so it wasn't just
that the attacks were fast although they
were but it was actually like massed
strikes so they attacked fast yes but
they were able to sustain that attack
and follow up on it for a long time
which is actually the same thing that
Napoleon did so in the Napoleonic Wars
before he came along people were
stretching out their troops further and
further to try and flank their enemies
and then he's like well if everyone's
gonna do that I'm actually just gonna
pack all my troops in the middle and
then like punch a hole in the middle of
their lines
um and I think like to go back to
the Amazon example like I think that has
big applications in business as well
of why haven't you heard the phrase
Blitz scale
there you go that's Reid Hoffman right
yeah
of uh it's not just going fast although
fast is important but it's that like
focusing tons of resources on a small
focal point so I like to go back to the
Amazon example it's starting with
bookstores right starting with just
books like I'm gonna take tons of
resources and just focus on this tiny
place and then follow up on that Victory
I'm gonna win books first and then I'm
going to follow up on that with with
other marginal victories yeah yeah and
uh so that was interesting to me that
like
that is what all all of them did that's
what Napoleon did that's what Hitler did
uh that's what Caesar did is this like
taking tons of resources and focusing
them on a very small Point taking lots
of gravity and kind of narrowing the
focus so I that was one interesting
takeaway for me what else did they did
they have that they did a lot of like
conquerors which I don't I don't even
know how we would Define a conqueror but
there's like the stereotypes of like a
Napoleon uh I don't know like what would
a a good American uh leader example of
this would be but like whoever we
describe it as what what else do they
have in common or even the business
people like uh Edison or something
yeah I mean so for me the number one you
know you mentioned Edison and the one I
think I think of is
total Obsession right
um with Edison the big thing that
clicked for me was he was inventing
so much that uh he was basically not
eating super skinny super gaunt he
wasn't washing his clothes he smelled
bad he was barely sleeping he would like
invent and Tinker until he fell asleep
at his workbench and then he'd like wake
up in the morning and like start
inventing again his family was worried
about him and I was like oh man like
substitute inventing for meth or heroin
and be very clear that this guy was an
addict that he was a junkie and I that's
when it clicked for me oh all of these
people who are super successful have
addictive personalities it just so
happens that they're addicted to
something that is considered positive
was he born that way you think or a lot
of people are they born this way
I think so and if you look at the
numbers people who achieve a lot CEOs uh
you'd think that like they don't have
problems with substance abuse right
because these are highly functioning
people but it actually turns out that
they have higher rates of addiction and
substance abuse than the general
population when they study it and so I
think they are born
with this propensity
to addiction and they're the kinds of
people that like they could end up
you know conquering a vast European
Empire or
they get hooked on a lot in them when
they're like a teenager and end up a
junkie on the streets right like they're
gonna end up addicted to something let's
just hope it's something positive dude
have you read uh have you ever heard of
this book called The First Rate Madness
I think it's called
no so this author has this premise where
he was like in times of like stability
um a non-mental ill mentally ill leader
is needed but in times of turmoil which
includes like the American Civil War or
includes like someone
um who's like trying to dominate and
Conquer or it includes like MLK you know
trying to like uh during the Civil
Rights Movement is like a non or sorry a
mentally ill leader during those periods
is actually ideal and they tend to be
better and the author explains like well
first let's define mentally ill and it's
like uh a propensity to like be addicted
to drugs and alcohol or like huge bouts
of depression or in Lincoln's case he
actually tried to kill himself like two
or three times before he became
president or uh Churchill Churchill was
like uh I've thought about killing
myself a ton but I'm just too big of a
in order to do it but like I I and
so and he became he was an alcoholic uh
and so like they basically just talk
about how the great great leaders during
uh troubled periods
majority of them have mental illness
yeah and um
this is something again to go back to Mr
Beast that yeah uh I actually don't know
if I I'll just say this and we'll see if
I should cut it or not but I was talking
with him and he was like yeah
I can't really gamble because I'm kind
of a gambling addict and uh he talked
about like
um
yeah I don't want to say the name of the
game highly addicting uh uh crypto
gambling site that he would be wagering
like tens of thousands of dollars on
yeah man I I well that's no secret
though like people who are who get there
they are and that's what I realized is
that for for him
YouTube is another form of gambling
right because like you put out the video
and who knows how it's gonna do and then
you get that dopamine hit of like oh
this got 50 million views like it's very
similar that variability the way that
the algorithm can pick it up make
anything go viral
um it's just it's just this gambling
addiction put into something positive
right and so I think that's very much
exactly what you're saying that for a
lot of these people
in normal circumstances they can't just
chill and be happy and be normal
um they have to be like running at such
a high uh level they have to be running
at a 10 at all times and that's good I
remember circumstances but not in normal
circumstances I don't even want to talk
about Mr Beast that much because we've
like kind of like
done that plenty but uh I remember at
like 11 p.m at night
someone mentioned basketball and how
excited he was to play basketball and
Jimmy he goes let's just go right now
and we were like what dude it's like 11
o'clock no one goes yeah yeah let's
figure it out and as he said that his
assistants were calling High School gyms
trying to wake up like the principals
and being like hey I'll give you five
grand if we can come play basketball
right now and I was like what no dude I
don't want to do that it sounds like
hell but but he was serious he wanted to
go do it yeah
yeah it was weird it was crazy who who
have you met besides him that you'd put
in that category of these like obsessed
like almost conqueror types whatever
whatever we're calling this this
personality type who have you met that
kind of has that Gene other than him
uh you I think you uh kind of have a
screw loose uh in that way like look at
the way you approach Fitness
um like you have trouble dipping your
toes into things
yeah that's for sure and you've talked
about you're you're you have an
addictive personality as well I do
but yeah I think I definitely am crazy I
think though that I don't have
the drive like I I am a little bit more
self-aware where I'm like uh no I don't
want to do that that sounds too hard uh
but yeah I'm definitely crazy uh in that
Obsession regard yeah yeah
[Music]
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better I'll give
you one yeah give me one do you know who
Tucker Max is yeah so Tucker Max is this
author he's my friend
um I haven't talked to him in a while
but I used to be buddies with them and
he's an author he wrote a I hope they
serve beer in hell now he has a company
and lately he's taking kind of like a
fairly
right turn or I don't know what you
wanted to call it where he like writes
these articles predicting that the
world's gonna end and I don't agree with
anything that he says about that type of
thing I mean I agree that like okay cool
prepare and be like self-sufficient but
I don't think the world's gonna end and
I disagree with so many of his point of
views but whenever I hang out with him
and I hear him talk in my head I'm like
I think you are wrong I think you're
wrong I think you're wrong and yet I
find myself buying like like fighting
myself from buying into what you are
saying even though logically I'm like no
that's I don't believe that that's true
for these following reasons but when I
get around them I'm like dude you like
are so confident you are such a good
Storyteller you have such strong energy
driving you into One Direction it's
sucking me in and so I would find myself
having to like pinch myself to him like
like dude you gotta snap out of it and
Tucker Max has that hardcore and if you
read his writing it even it comes
through in his writing you'll read
something and you'll say oh this guy's
totally right and then I gotta go and
like read something that's the opposite
like oh well there are counterpoints
yeah yeah I so I just thought of one
that's a little like uh I guess Off the
Wall his name is alanay jokes uh he was
uh on Circuit Court of Appeal he was one
of the highest judges in the United
States was on the short list to be on
the Supreme Court for Reagan
um but then didn't become a Supreme
Court Justice ended up becoming an
apostle for the church Jesus Christ of
Latter-day Saints is now the number two
person in the church uh is set to take
over the church probably in a few years
what I found interesting is I think that
was the first time I met him when I was
like 16 uh that I encountered true
Charisma and it felt different than I
thought it would feel because when I
talked to him
he talked to me for like 10 minutes
unbelievably Charmed me like I couldn't
believe it but the impression I had
coming away was wow I'm so smart
because he was so good at I don't want
to say manipulating but like
at playing on my feelings and just being
like wow that's really interesting what
you know and just kind of like getting
me to feel comfortable and divulge
information about myself and
um like focusing all his attention on me
that I came away and I was like man I'm
super special and I think that's what
truly charismatic people do people think
that it's like inward magnetism but it
almost goes the opposite direction of
like somehow they're able to make you
feel like you're the special one and uh
and then you like get like drunk on that
almost totally I've been uh I used to
work for this guy named John Cobbs John
Rin this company called apartment list
they bought my other business and I
don't know how big they are now maybe
it's like 100 they've raised maybe one
or 200 million dollars in funding and
like they're probably gonna go public or
I I met that's what they have to do and
this guy I was only 22 when I worked
there and he would give these talks at
the office and I'm like oh my gosh I
believe that I am and we weren't even
doing anything interesting it was just
like a Zillow competitor which was like
not exactly the most sexy thing we're
not saving the Earth we're not going to
the moon like there's nothing like it's
just a cool money making scheme and a
slightly better way to maybe find an
apartment in some cities and I remember
like hearing him talk and I'm like I am
so we are we are democratizing housing
and like we are like I am so on board
with this we are making people's lives
so much better and like it we owe it to
the world to do this and he has just
shown me that it is possible and you
begin to think that rules don't apply to
you and you say it's US versus everyone
which is a common tactic and occult and
you should always do this in a good
company which is you have you and then
you have the enemy and everyone's out to
to on the enemy side and it's US versus
them and you have to create that Dynamic
and also I felt with him whenever he
would give these talks on a Friday we
used to have this thing where Friday at
four he would give a talk and I remember
thinking like rules don't apply to us
like what yeah and I and I've heard
stories about Travis kalanick at Uber
and I remember the people it was like
the same thing they were like breaking
laws and they're like they're it wasn't
these laws we shouldn't be breaking them
it was these laws shouldn't exist and
they are wrong and we need to prove to
them that they are wrong you know what I
mean and I remember hearing that and you
just get intoxicated with it yeah you
know who's uh who's pretty good at this
uh I found uh from Camp MFM is suely uh
your friends you think so yeah just like
when I was talking to him I think he
kind of brain raped me a little bit like
why at the end I don't know I just at
the end he just was like so interested
in me and then I was just like did I
just tell suly like everything about my
life and like everything yeah and like
and he won't tell you a thing about his
no yeah I was like how is it that like
you're the multi-millionaire like you
have the successful business that you
saw like you've done all this impressive
stuff and like we just spent 20 minutes
talking about me and like you know
everything about me and I don't know
anything about you at the end of this
how did this happen he's so good at it I
don't know yeah he's good at it so is
Ben Levy Sean's partner Sean he's really
good at that man Ben I always call Ben a
shark uh but he's not actually a shark
because he doesn't mean he's not gonna
like harm you probably well maybe I
don't know I don't think so but he uh
like he's so good where I'll have to
stop myself I'm like dude shut the
up I don't you don't need to tell this
guy all this like it's good to be
privates about some stuff and he's so
good at getting stuff out of getting
stuff out of you
um he's really good at that yeah so yeah
those people they they are good at that
they um
another guy is um
who I found myself getting like
intoxicated with there's a couple people
uh
uh Sam bankman freed you know the guy
from uh uh what's his what what the the
you know Bitcoin what's his company
called
um
FTX something has another one I think uh
anyway FTX when I hear him talk I just
think like oh you're right about
everything like I don't wanna I like I
can't have and it's hard for me to
understand anything than other than what
you believe because you've just
logically shown to me that this is all
true even though I'm like you have to
remind I have to remind myself like this
guy's just a 29 year old smart guy which
is cool and all but like he's just a guy
he's just a dude he's still figuring out
just like I am but I will hear him talk
and I'm I buy into everything he's
saying and another good person is
Malcolm Gladwell if you ever read a
Malcolm Gladwell Book You'll Think oh
everything you're saying is facts in
reality a lot of it's just theories and
he'll say this is just my this is just a
theory based off of the data who knows
if I'm right or wrong this is just an
idea but I'll read his stuff and I think
oh this is this is just how the world is
and my takeaway from that is
storytelling is so important it's so
important
I I think that Malcolm Gladwell is full
of crap most of his stuff is like of
little to no value anyone who asked me
how to do storytelling I'm like just go
listen to Malcolm gladwell's podcast and
analyze every single sentence like it
doesn't matter what you think of
what he has to say I think he's this
generation's most gifted Storyteller and
it's like not close dude he's so good
he's so good he's unbelievable he's
unbelievable he gets you intoxicated is
what he does you feel like this
intoxication and you feel like
of course this is the answer what you're
saying is true and I have to purposely
go and seek out like other opinions to
be like oh well you know I gotta remind
myself this isn't necessarily true it
might be but maybe not
Ogilvy has this good quote uh David
ogleby like uh very famous copywriter
and Advertiser uh that the job of the
first sentence is to get you to read the
second sentence and the job second
sentence is to get you to read the third
sentence and if you read Gladwell with
that lens uh that framework in mind he's
such a master like the first sentence of
every podcast is independently extremely
engaging and interesting and it gets you
to listen to the second sentence which
is itself extremely engaged and like
every single sentence is a masterpiece
that gets you to go into the next
sentence
um everyone should read it
um everyone should read and Listen to As
Much Gladwell as as they can what's the
name of his pod I forget it's called
something history
um revisionist history yeah it's good
man and he does he does a really good
job of uh voice inflections it doesn't
sound like it my voice is fairly
aggressive his voice is like soft and
welcoming and like warming and so his
inflections aren't like when Sean and I
talk and then we like get down low and
then we and we come right back up it's
way more subtle yeah but and everything
he says is like a kind of a whisper but
he's but but he like knows how to use
empty space and silence and then he
knows how to come back in and lead you
down and get you to come a little bit
more and then he'll break it to you you
know what I mean like he does his things
and I like I'm tripping it's called a
slippery slope that's what I call it the
same in the slippery slope is my name
for uh that copywriting concept of the
first sentence to get you to read the
seconds which is get you read the third
that's the slippery slope I want to pull
you down that slope because the further
I pull you along the more more button
you get and if you read like a Tony
Robbins book he'll say like I'm about to
tell you about one thing that's going to
change your life and he'll spend the
rest of that chapter saying we're we're
about to get to it we're getting to it
soon but before we do I need to tell you
why it's important and then like there's
a reveal at the end and oftentimes that
reveals a little bit anticlimactic but
you're so deep down this slippery slope
that you just you're you're bought in
and so that's what Malcolm Gladwell does
wonderfully he gets me to go down this
slope and he pulls me down and a lot of
the great
um
dictators and CEOs and these like
leaders both good and bad they were
awesome at uh being Auditors which is
something we don't really talk about
anymore but like Obama was like that
where I was like I heard Obama talk and
I'm like dude whatever you say yes I
like that it's seductive almost like
it's seductive it's seductive which the
root of all this is learning how to
write well and how to storytell and then
if possible how to speak how to speak it
can can I talk about one more attribute
that actually you and Sean have done a
good job with recently on getting me on
me about is um this idea of like bias to
action so for me my favorite story about
this is Napoleon comes into command of
oh the French army in Italy and it's
just been sitting there for months and
the the reason is they have they don't
have enough guns they don't have enough
ammunition they don't have enough shoes
they don't have enough clothes
um they're like horribly undersupplied
the morale is low and so the general
before Napoleon is like we cannot
they're fighting the austrians we cannot
go give battle to the austrians like
this we're in a horrible State and uh
Napoleon comes in and he's like okay so
today
I'm going to take account of everything
that's happening in this Army you're
going to give me an accounting of
exactly how many shoes we have the
status of everything and tomorrow we're
gonna march to go fight the austrians
and they're like this is a horrible idea
like you should not do this this Army's
in no shape to fight and he's basically
like yeah Isaac Newton an object at rest
stays at rest an object in motion stays
in motion and so like I don't care we're
going to go attack and so they go out
they attack they score cheap easy
Victory and then they're just rolling
right and then they roll through Italy
and kick the crap out of the austrians
in like a matter of weeks and so I you
know I've been talking to you and Sean
about doing better with how to take over
the world and and getting bigger and I'm
just like ah man I have all these
problems I like
I need more researchers I need more
writers because I have to do all this
research and both of you were just kind
of like like no you don't just
put stuff out like just put out more
episodes what's wrong with you just put
out more episodes and uh and so that's
something I've been focusing on is like
it's so easy to focus on all the inputs
on like getting everything ready on
planning on preparing and this biased
action of like no no no no
every single day you need to be taking
steps that have measurable outcomes uh
that Advance your goals forward you need
to be doing and you need to have a bias
towards doing those things rather than
planning and preparing dude and a good
example of that is like only six months
ago or something so we were fairly
popular Sean for some reason because
he's always a little disorganized his
microphone wasn't working and he's like
it I'm just gonna use my airpods
I'm like all right fine and he puts his
airpods in and
only one of them worked and the other
one didn't even work it was for some
reason it was out of battery he goes
we're just like screw it we're going to
record this shot with just your webcam
at your one airpods dude that airpod is
gonna be your microphone and your like
how you could hear me talk he's like
yeah let's do it versus waiting 20
minutes for it to get charged we're like
no we can't wait we have to do it right
now we have to go and uh I think that
that is the way to go I think that the
world wants you to be vanilla the world
wants to make everyone vanilla and they
want you to be safe and that means
planning planning and so so many people
write on their goals for the day I bet
you there's a lot of people listening
they have one task today which says plan
workout or plan you know like business
like what how I'm going to launch this
like plan something it's like that's
there to do and that's really just kind
of a self-masturbation uh like it's a uh
uh it's a way to make you think
that you actually are doing something
when instead you should just start and
figure it out along the way because
virtually everything not everything but
almost everything related to a project
is reversible
you should always start and so you
should always just like just make it
happen and always have a bias to action
because it also is intoxicating
right right
dude have you ever sold anything on the
internet
um
no so like people talk to me about like
how do I do this how do I do that I'm
like dude just whatever you do
build it so you can get it live tomorrow
and so then you can get just one dollar
in Revenue in the first five days
because the second your phone goes
because like I have this thing on
Shopify that goes kaching every sale I
get the SEC the first time you hear that
you're like oh I need to feel that again
let's go let's go let's go let's go like
it gets you amped up when you hear that
and so that's why whenever people talk
to me they're like which platform should
I use for my new blog I'm like it
doesn't matter just go to subsec right
now and make your blog post live
tomorrow and then the second you see
traffic on the analytics you're like oh
I like that that tastes good I like how
that feels I gotta do it again I need
more I need to get another bite and
that's why whenever people talk about
anything they want to do I'm like if
you're a noob
launch right away immediately
immediately if you're like I have this
guy named Brett adecock who sold a
company for
two or three billion dollars and as the
next company it's like a robot business
and he's investing 200 million dollars
in like five years of research I'm like
all right that's cool you're a proven
hit maker like take your time and like
perfect this thing but if you're like a
rookie you gotta Jump Right In and get
that taste of dopamine immediately
otherwise it will never happen or it
just Fades and you just aren't
interested anymore
so it's interesting what you're saying
reminds me a little bit of uh like the
difference between the Greeks and the
Romans so the Greeks like masters of the
Mediterranean the old Greeks and Roman
okay okay hear me out though because
here's the thing the Greeks were like
much better academics than the Romans
they knew geometry they knew algebra
they knew like philosophy right in the
Romans were basically dumb jocks okay
they didn't know any of this stuff and
it turns out that Roman construction and
bridges were actually much better than
Greek ones why is it because the Greeks
would sit down and try and figure out
the geometry of the best way to build a
bridge the Romans did not the Romans
just went out and built a bridge and
then it kind of crumbled and then
they're like oh what if we did this and
then they rebuilt it and then that
didn't work out so well and then over
the generations they just went out and
did stuff until eventually they had like
the perfect way to build a bridge that
would stand forever did they ever know
the math behind it they literally never
did they just went and tried stuff until
they found the thing that worked best
and that was what let them take over the
world and so that just like backs up
what you're saying of like you actually
don't need to know why this stuff is
working you don't need to know the math
behind it you don't need to do the
research you just literally need to try
stuff until you find out what works well
John what I was gonna say I think you
know two things I just heard was one uh
and this is all kind of wrapping this
back up to how this applies to like
podcasting
um I Heard bias towards action which is
just like go go and I also heard like be
very methodical with how you tell
stories like Malcolm Gladwell ask so
like let's just say you're starting a
podcast today zero to twenty five
thousand downloads buy swords action 25
to 100 000 let's just say you're really
dialing in the storytelling component of
it and then but it sounds like you're
flipping back to okay just bias towards
action go go so like I don't know I
think it could be helpful to go from
like at this stage you want to focus on
just making happen versus being
more methodical with how actually level
the podcast up that kind of stuff can I
use an example like Danny Miranda you
were on his podcast a few days ago uh
Sam and I don't think he's figured out
his Niche very well
um he needs to work on that he he hasn't
figured out yet but guess what he's in a
really good position to figure it out
because he just got started he's been
doing great interviews he's super action
oriented and he's going to figure out
the data and he's got the data right and
now he can pivot and he can try
different stuff he can think about
different ways to position it versus the
person who is just like no no Danny's
not doing it the right way I need to
position my podcast perfectly no just
start with action you can figure out
your Niche and exactly how to position
your podcast later dude it's because
it's way better to execute a bad plan
than it is to execute no plan and
because you can change it you can change
a bad plate into a good plan in most
cases as you go but you can't you know
you're up creek if you're doing
nothing all day yep
[Music]